[Music]
the best thing about boxing is just the
sweet science it's a mental thing I love
the hard work when I'm winning I know
that those nights being homeless being
bullied and everything that I have been
through will always be with me going out
there I don't really have any fears or
any doubts because I know the only
person that can beat me is me and I will
never forget what it took to get there
[Music]
my name is Naomi Graham I'm from
Fayetteville North Carolina and I'm a
boxer for Team USA I compete in middle
weight which is 165 pounds 75 kilograms
and I like to consider my style very
unique
I don't just compete one way
[Music]
I can box and move I can walk you down
and I feel like I have a really good job
my name is Billy Walsh I'm head coach of
USA a boxing team to become a boxer
within this program a boxer is kind of
many many qualities not only you need to
be able to fight but you need to have a
good lifestyle we've got you know
Freddie a structure a damn camp for Team
USA
looks like waking up at 7:00 weighing in
training eating and doing strength and
conditioning and training again and
going to bed about 9:00 most of the kids
that's in this program started boxing at
7 & 8 years of age so to be boxing ahead
of a long time there is the exception to
the road I'm 30 years old and when I
started boxing I was 22 years old my
mother she looked at me as being fragile
her baby but youngest she didn't really
want me to box
[Music]
I'm sitting out on the front porch at my
house but Naomi grew up we've been here
about 20 years I guess my name is Bertha
Clark I'm living in Fayetteville North
Carolina Naomi is my sixth child she's
my baby
you know and when she got into that
profession boxing you know I wouldn't
fool it at first my mother was a single
parent she put in a lot of hours to take
care of six kids I was a battered
bruised wife but God delivered me out of
there you know the children we come
through together you know and we don't
we rising together
[Music]
Fayetteville is a military town it's
pretty quiet
[Music]
there's a lot of boxing gyms to go to
and that's where I spent a lot of my
time following my sister's Rachel to her
practices a lot of times I saw the blood
sweat and tears that she put into it and
I wanted that I wanted something to
drive me just as much as it was driving
her when you believe something and you
got faith in your heart that you're
gonna do it and you put work toward it
you're gonna make it being the youngest
I spent a lot of time to myself for many
years I was bullied because I was so
quiet and my mother believed that if
someone is picking on you you just tell
the teacher you don't engage with the
student so because of that I also got
picked on even more one time I was
forced to fight back but I don't
consider myself violent outside of the
ring inside of the ring it's a it's a
chess match it's it's more strategic
it's it's not about violence I got what
it takes
[Music]
always going hard no matter what they
say my next competition is the Penn
American Games in Lima Peru these games
a particularly important from an eye on
me in boxing terms it's the third
largest in the world
you got the Pan Am's dam you got a World
Championships a demigod Olympic Games
[Music]
there should be three fights each fight
that you win you would go to the next
level and the third fight should be the
finals I'm in Lima Peru I've been here
almost a week I'm feeling very confident
about this tournament I'm excited I'm
ready to go ahead and get gold I'm
excited Marino's category residentes
Cinco kilos worth of the finale
[Music]
[Applause]
the hardest part of training is the
mental you could be the most talented
boxer but if you're not there mentally
you can't be successful I've always been
that type of person to any adversity or
any problems or difficulties I feel like
I need to handle them on my own I became
homeless
when I was 21 my mother decided that I
needed to get myself together and figure
it out on my own I found a home that was
abandoned and that's where I stayed
mostly in the back room mostly at night
is when I would go by the home I didn't
know where I wanted to go what I was
gonna do with my life and I didn't know
what was the next step from there a lot
of the nights I was in deep thought of
what I really wanted for myself and the
person that I wanted to be a lot of my
decisions were made in the dark in the
band at home the last night that I spent
in the home homeless I was in the back
room and I said this is it you're gonna
be bigger than anyone else expected you
to be yesterday I got a second round TKO
which is the stoppage a win against
Mexico
[Music]
now that I got the wind yesterday I am
preparing for this in my finals against
Brazil
tomorrow the 30th
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the first step to change in my life
after I was homeless was joining the
army my first duty station was here in
Colorado Springs Colorado Colorado
Springs is where Team USA trains for
boxing but I didn't know that at the
time that I got stationed here I said
that I was just trying on my own someone
saw me in a gym and they said well
you're in the military you should go to
all army so I went there and you have to
either beat a double you cap member and
then place the top four at a national
tournament I did both the first yes that
I received was from W cap this is the
world-class athlete program this is
actually where everything started and
this is where I'm training when I'm not
with Team USA a lot of hours spent on
the speed bags this is where the blood
sweat and tears started it was very
painful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Joe Guzman and I'm one of the
volunteer coaches with the national
boxing team
so I met Naomi Graham about five or six
years ago I was working as one of the
assistant coaches in the world class
acting program I would be on the bag and
I saw him kind of looking at me and he
was saying you know do you have any
fights you know I see potential in you
one thing that really stood out to me
from the beginning was just her worth
ethic you know she did everything she
did she did it like a hundred percent
coach Guzman he was very important to me
learning myself as a boxer that what it
would take to be on top
my highest point in w cap was when I won
the 2017 national championships well
once you win a national title you're
automatically on Team USA from that
moment on tomorrow is the gold medal
bout and I will be competing against
Columbia she's more of an aggressive
fighter so I'm definitely gonna have to
work my job a lot with her and stay to
my right
winner on points and women's in middle
age 75
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stand up and fire
[Music]
sometimes if you don't push your child
out then you're hindering them sometimes
in life you need that struggle you need
that wrestle you know so you can know
just how much to take a weight which
direction you want to go you know what
I'm saying
if it wasn't for my mother
I couldn't possibly be where I am today
she showed me you know that she was
tough all my life what name is doing now
pleases me
because she spoke it back in the past
and it's coming to manifestation and
nobody can get where Naomi's at without
hard work without some sacrifices
without some pain my tattoo is actually
of my mother and I just want to take her
everywhere that I go
my right arm is much stronger that's
another reason why I got my tattoo on my
right arm I think boxing you know really
really takes to test your character they
actually builds character test
everything that you have inside of you
you know and I think the teachers a
discipline you know and teaches you
manners and it gives you a lot of
qualities that will will stand to you in
life last five years for Graham I mean
she's really stepped it up so I mean
she's on a great path of making this
Olympic team for sure my ultimate goal
is to go to the Olympics and win gold
the sky is the limit and anything that
you want to be in life you can do that
and I want to show everybody that no
matter what you're going through
no matter anything that happens in your
life you can be whatever you want to be
[Music]
this is this is this
[Music]
hi Meili what is it like for you like
being in the ring and fighting you want
me to show you get up and go through the
roof that's what happens when you're six
five you just get in over at the top so
I know that you won silver correct which
means you didn't win gold correct yes so
let's talk about that just a little bit
not because you lost but I can tell you
that people talked a lot about my
accolades of what I've won but it was
the losses that really I held on to the
longest that helped me win again I feel
like it fuels my drive even more so
really they feel like they're winning
but they're actually pushing me so
really they're gonna be on the losing
end so I see that's good I love that yes
perhaps it has to be your motivation
watching you don't that was that was
amazing moment for me because I realized
women can do anything that they want to
do it was an amazing moment your are you
ready now to be a role model cuz when
these young girls get a chance to see
you you're gonna be in that same
position to stop and sign autographs
yeah it's an awesome opportunity
[Music]
thank you so much best of luck and I
also want to say thank you for your
service representing our country it's no
problem at all
I'm Lisa Leslie and this is the bleacher
report
[Music]